president biden is spending new year's
weekend at his home in wilmington
delaware and he's facing rising tensions
with russia to begin 2022. on friday he
spoke to reporters about his phone call
this week with russian president
vladimir putin schuyler henry is at the
white house with the latest schuyler
good morning
haley good morning to you and a happy
new year to you as well well it was a
relatively quiet week for president
biden however he did have that hour-long
phone call with russian president
vladimir putin it was a call requested
by the kremlin the two men discussed the
ongoing concerns at the russian
ukrainian border as well as other
security issues it was the second time
the two spoke in the last few weeks
white house officials also say president
biden will be speaking with ukrainian
president vladimir silinski at some
point tomorrow reaffirming the us's
support for ukraine's sovereignty
that meeting stems from growing fears of
a russian invasion into ukraine now
moscow stays around 100 000 troops along
ukraine's border but denies imminent
invasion in early december russia
removed around 10 000 troops from the
area however those with intelligence
suspect a possible invasion in the
coming weeks while russian officials
have downplayed that saying that is not
their intent now president biden was
asked about that yesterday when he and
the first lady were out to lunch he said
that he made it clear to putin that if
an invasion were to happen there would
be severe sanctions and an increased u.s
presence in europe with nato allies now
president biden also said that russia
has agreed to three conferences in
europe starting in geneva in nine days
president biden also adding that
progress would only continue if
president putin de-escalated the
situation on the ukrainian border
president biden and president putin
meeting again on january 10th to
continue those security talks elise a
lot to keep watching skyler henry at the
white house thanks